afterwards um you can use it to indicate
that you want to speak and then take it
down again afterwards
and so on we will do the voting
in line with the procedure and the rules
in our
constitution i'll first check on whether
we want a recorded vote if that number's
reached
then we'll take the the recorded vote
but if no recorded vote is requested
voting will be done by a show of hands
and clicking the raised hand icon
um it looks like we're already
live on our youtube channel and
streaming
so please be aware that we are um
we we are on show to uh the wider public
and the meeting is being recorded
so um without
further ado
i think just
i think right i think i've got all my
papers in order so
all right members welcome to the
development committee on the 25th of
march
2021
we've got quite a lot to get through
this evening
including some speakers so i will ask
in advance that all members are concise
with their comments um i will give
everyone the opportunity to speak
but due to the the the number of items
that we've got
um it's quite possible that we will be
limited on your opportunity to come back
um with with subsequent points and
subsequent questions
so please do your best to cover all that
you
wish to say in your initial speech
because it is important that we we get
through our business this evening
um item one is apologies for absence
they've been received from councillor
iano
and councillor weston item two is our
substitutes
which for councillor iano is councillor
wilkinson
and for councillor western it is
councillor steptoe
our non-members attending we have
councillor rowe council award
council hoy councillor whatton
councillor gooding
and i think that is uh
is is everybody so welcome to you all
welcome to our
um our speakers who are
already with us and
of course welcome to anyone that is
watching us
on the youtube channel uh item four is
the minutes of the meeting held on the
25th
of february 2021 um i'll take it that
you accept those unless
anyone indicates otherwise
let's give a moment and i don't
see anyone indicated thank you for that
item five is declarations of interest
on behalf of all members i
will just i will declare our
non-pecuniary
interest on items nine and items
ten so there's no need to mention those
separately counsellor steptoe
chairman uh obviously declare interest
as a county council
member but also items nine and ten other
than what you have just said
uh other directors partners of the
business there
are known to me thank you
counselor mr shaw thank you chairman
item 8 i'm chairman of stanbridge paris
council
and item 11 i'm ward councillor
for that item thank you
counselor mrs shaw
thank you chairman i to make
non-capunary interest
i am the wall counsellor one of the wall
councillors and i do know this applicant
but i have had no dealings with it on
this application
thank you councillor williams
thank you chairman and non-pecuniary
interest on items nine and ten
like others being that i'm also chairman
of rochester parish council
thank you item six
the applicant has asked that this item
be removed
from the uh agenda so that is done
item seven is um
106. lower road
home bridge which is an outline
application to demolish garage
workshops to construct 12 flats mr
stranks
is going to take us through this one
please thank you
thank you chairman um this application
is to a site
of a filling station and service garage
on the southern side of lower road
opposite the junction made with
hillcrest avenue that you can see
edged red on the screen before you the
uses on the site are no longer in
operation and the site is fenced off
if we could jump to the picture
sorry the um bird's eye view if you
wouldn't mind if
that's pick two birdseye from north
members will see that the site has an
error of 0.21 hectares thank you
and extends out of depth to the rear
backing on to
the rayleigh golf club course
houses are joined either side as you can
see from this image
and there are chalet bungalows on the
opposite side of the
street the site is to an elevated
position more or less at the top
of coventry hill the application for
consideration is an outline application
to demolish the existing buildings that
we can see here in structures and
construct a development of 12
self-contained flats the application
particular state each flat would be
two-bedroomed with five flats to both
ground and first floors with two flats
in the roof space the application is
submitted to seek
only the principle of the development
with all matters of access
out layout appearance scale and
landscaping all reserved for the
necessary reserved matters application
that would follow the grant of outline
permission should members grant it
the plans submitted are therefore
indicative labour that point
and submitted only to demonstrate that
quantum of development sort can fit the
site
if we can uh jump to plan indicative
layer thank you uh those indicative
plans that you see there on the right
hand side you'll see the existing
situation with the
buildings existing on the site and if
you look at the left hand side it's an
indicative layout of what might be
possible
but that building is shown in a purple
dotted outline if you can follow that
it can be seen that the applicant has
considered the 45 degree test that we
apply primarily to
household or extensions but officers do
rely on this also when considering
other matters it's a useful tool it
takes the more or less approximate
position of the nearest window looking
rearwards and a judge is the impact of
what might be
overshadowing and dominance upon those
particularly
primary rooms such as kitchens and
lounges etc
it is suggested that the existing access
points in this layout
if thank you claire you'll see that
there's being a filling station is no
doubt gotten in our facility and the
applicant is suggesting at least in this
indicative plan
um that they could be made use of
providing a small car parking area to
the front of the
site as claire is indicating with the
cursor there
and then access to the majority of the
car parking and amenity space behind the
building
down the side of the building adjoining
number 104.
the amenity area that's shown would
equate to a surplus of
uh 60 square meters some 360 square
meters in area
that is more than required for the 12
flats proposed
and members will see at paragraph 3.42
to the report that officers consider
that the parking shortfall which was
three spaces you only see i think 24
spaces there and 27 would be required
for a scheme of this size
could be met from that 60 square meters
shortfall
so bearing in mind that members aren't
being asked to consider this layout it's
just to help
the council as a whole come to a view
that the development would fit
officers district officers feel that the
shortfall in car parking could be met
from the surplus and amenity space
provision
if we see the street scene um
again only indicative but bearing in
mind comments raised about the potential
height
and members are not being asked to
consider this but the applicant has
suggested again
this is the kind of thing that they may
have in mind should permission be
granted
and that may help members to understand
the quantum of development and how it
might
might look um the elevation would
require sensitivity given the
uh raised area of land but that i don't
think
should be uh resulting in a squashed or
suppressed building bearing in mind that
many prominent landmarks churches pubs
buildings like that can often be
successfully provided
on a high elevated ground
and as the majority of the buildings
that are
to story in the locality some vertical
increase in scale would depending on the
design
um could be a attractive uh on the final
solution
if outlined planet mission is granted
members would get that
opportunity to assess that design at the
reserve matters stage
you can't build an outline permission if
it's granted you would have to
come along with all the matters that we
can't consider tonight as a separate
application what an outline permission
does it gives them agreement in
principle
it establishes anything with necessary
through 106 contributions etc
and allows the developer to proceed with
confidence on the understanding that he
could get
12 units on the site
uh the site falls within a predominantly
residential area
so district officers are advising this
would be the most suitable
use the use would redevelop what appears
to be a redundant site with a
residential use more compatible with
adjoining residential uses removing
commercial noise from workshops and
fumes from field storage
the provision of two-bedroom
accommodation would help diversify the
local housing weeks redressing the
dominance of larger particularly
detached and semi-detached housing
the development would have potential to
provide two shared ownership affordable
units
unless a provider cannot be found in
which case the officers are recommending
a financial
contribution be set out as uh you can
see in the recommendation
that recommendation is therefore
approval chairman subject to the
applicant entering into an agreement
under section 106 of the act
to secure the provision of affordable
housing and
or um the financial contributions
um and to the conditions set out in the
report
thank you um
just one point before we go any further
councillor hookway you
joined um partway through this
presentation
i think given the rules uh that were
working under it
it wouldn't be appropriate for you to
vote on this particular application when
the time comes
i hope you understand that position um
yes sharon thank you understand thank
you thank you
uh right members um count councillor hoy
as a visiting member and this is uh this
is your award i believe
um would you like to start
uh yes thank you chairman um
i do have concerns about this
application um
and i would also like to mention that
although it
is an outline planning permission and as
uh mr strength says indicative of what
could happen
i have found in the past that items
which may be
mentioned or specified in this report
will be
will be assumed to be acceptable
when they are put in the reserve matters
report
and this has happened previously so i
want to draw attention some of the areas
i've got concerns about which aren't
necessarily
specific to the outline but maybe more
specific to the style and design and the
height
this is clearly we've seen the
indicative plans that's been shown by mr
strength on our screen
um the first thought i'd like to point
out about the
the swans which is the picture that was
shown of the building which was
significantly taller than the ones
either side of it
as planned which is what they're
suggesting they might like to build
there
the swans is in a different part of hole
which is well over a mile
from this site and it is
near the river and is along a short
stretch of road which has
if you like buildings of the same
stature there are flattened areas there
and large
detached houses which were quite high
roof lines
so they don't stand out they're not
they're amongst
similar buildings and it's likely that
will happen for a couple more at least
along that but it'd be the road and that
is not a problem
this part of holbridge is a mixed street
scene it's
detached semi-detached houses and as you
you saw in the the previous map it's not
necessarily chalet bungalows i say
they're bungalows
opposite so it's much more mixed
i i think from the first point of view
um that we as councillors should
shouldn't really be agreeing
to something that is going to be such so
significantly taller than the buildings
around it particularly on such a high
point this is very close to the highest
point in holbridge
um a few meters up the road and it is
the highest point
i think this will be dominating the
street scene and he's not at all in
keeping with the street
scene as it is shown
um the
the other issue is there are no flats in
the area at all the nearest one's
probably a half a mile away down the
hill
there's mention in this report of it
of it being on a sustainable trend or
or talk of sustainable transport links
it's one bus route which is about half a
mile away which would be the number 20
which stops running um every 15 minutes
or every 20 minutes
at about 8 o'clock at night and you you
may be able to get a last bus into
holbridge
about half 10 quarter to 11
it leaves holbridge um around 11 o'clock
one bus and that's it so it i i don't
regard it as a state sustainable as as
the report
um the the um applicants feel it is
um that's really
i think the rest can wait to the reserve
matters of i've got concerns about cars
being parked next to gardens
along that along those lines um but but
that can be reserved matters that's not
a problem but at the moment i'm
i'd just like councillors to think about
the the size and bulk of the building
that was shown
and whether or not that's appropriate in
this area i'd
i personally think that it should be
restricted to two stories
and i don't know if it's at all possible
now that the report could put a
condition that it
it can't be above the existing
um ridge line of of the properties
either side of it
um that's what i have to say at the
moment thank you chairman
thank you um i don't see any other
non-members indicating
so i'll move on then um
counselor wilson pleases
thank you chairman i'm not going to
repeat the points that are raised by
council high
um only to well the first one really my
point is it's unfortunate that we've
lost the local business but
that's that's where we are um but it is
to follow up really about this
implication from the the the plans that
were shown
i know they're indicative and i know
that we'll we would do this at reserve
matters state
um but my concern
is that if we give outline planning
permission for 12
flats it's almost implied from the plans
that were shown
that these will need to be taller than
the existing buildings the ridgeline is
is important for me
and i'm not sure whether if we go to
this is a question really for offices if
we go to reserve matters
and it turns out that we think the size
and the scale is too large
but we've given permission for 12 flats
where does that leave us thank you
chairman thank you we'll gather up
questions
at the end for efficiency of time
councillor wilkinson please
thank you chair um i can only support
the comments that have been made i have
serious concerns with outline planning
consents from bitter experience within
my own ward in raleigh with um
uh crown hill and it and the same as
councilor wilson said it it gives me
grave concerns
um that once outlined planning consent
is granted
for 12 units um we're stuck um and even
when it comes to reserve matters
um this is exactly what happened uh in
crown hill
um outline consent was given for five
flats and when they tried to put it on
there
they found it particularly difficult but
we had to grant it because outline
consent was given
um and i i i'm concerned about that the
other thing that concerns me as well
is um i i hear what mr strength said
about the parking
um i would expect um if i was going to
be on the committee when this comes for
the full consideration that we don't
consider the three extreme parking
spaces they must be included
uh within that 60 square meters and i
would think that should be there
the other thing is and i don't know
whether or not the the um at the
appropriate time
the the pictorial image could be shown
again of the
the bird's eye view but whereabouts is
the amenity space because it looked as
though
there was a little bit of parking at the
front then there was the building there
was a lot of parking behind
and then the amenity space was right at
the back so in other words anybody
coming out of the building
this new building has to go past the car
park to get to the
the garden space which i suppose it's up
to each person wants to buy the unit but
it doesn't seem particularly attractive
to me so just interested with that is
my concern is the is the implication of
granting outline consent for 12 units
and if they have to squeeze it on there
because we've done it
we've tied ourselves in knots thank you
chairman thank you
yes thank you chairman um some of my
thunder has already been
uh stolen there by the previous speakers
uh i wouldn't disagree
with what council hawaii and others are
saying um
i always find it very sad personally to
see another garage disappearing but
that's for obvious reasons but picking
up on the
um the garden situation i would have
thought it would be
far more advisable to have the immunity
space
directly behind the building because if
there are children and things
in the uh in the flats rather than to
have them work or
walk across car parks and things um
makes more sense to me
so i'm i'm inclined to agree with the
other
speakers that um on this outline we are
opening ourselves up for something that
we may not want at the end of the day
thanks jeremy stanley
thank you chairman uh i can only uh
support what the
other speakers have said and the fact
that uh
granting the permission uh
for this development before we actually
have anything to say on it other than
uh the 12 flats i think there's so much
uh
difference of opinion on this i won't be
able to support it
okay um could us mr strengths to come
come back um and talk we
i think members are indicating that
they've got concerns
about what the size and bulk of a
proposed development might be
um compare against
12 units so if 12 units can't be
incorporated in
um something that we considered have a
reasonable size and bonk
where where does that how does that
argument play out please
chairman what is before you tonight
even though the applicant has tried to
help us with indicative plans to show
that his
scheme he thinks fits yeah or they think
sorry
fits um what is before you is to agree
the quantum as members have said
um sometimes they might feel that on a
constrained site
um permission has been given as said for
five and in their view five didn't
didn't fit
now this layout shows
that there is room to provide the
necessary garden space
even with taking some of it to provide
the car parking space shortfall
there's reasonable gaps and
relationships to the boundary we spoke
earlier about the
45 degree tests and
other policy things you know to do
recycling existing
sites and so forth so what the applicant
is showing
is a scheme to say i propose 12 12 units
and this is how i would fit them on the
site he's got
10 flats split between two floors but
he's got
two in the roofing system we we showed
i don't need you to to jump to that
clear but we showed
an indicative and that's that's the
important point an indicative elevation
they're showing of
how that might look now if members are
of
the view that the development should
only be two-story
it may well be that the developer can
fit or
whatever 12 flats still on there but at
two-story form
this is the point i think where members
have got to determine
if a scheme that would include some
accommodation in the roof space
would be acceptable it wouldn't be a
full three-story what we call two and a
half and that always
i agree gives us problems in description
or if members are
limiting it to two-story form without
accommodation above that
this is the point where members should
effectively refuse permission because
the applicant has one of the
limited particulars that they're obliged
to provide in this way
there's several ways you can apply for
an outline and this is one where they
leave everything to the reserve matters
stage other
than can we put 12 on the site so
if members are so clear that two stories
should be the maximum this is the time
that they should perhaps grant planning
permission but
with a condition to say that it be only
limited to two story
i would just while i'm in i heard a
comment about
limiting it to the same height of the
adjoining buildings
that would be i think rather unfair and
give up
i would suggest an opportunity to do a
good design if you
if you have the governance of the two
adjoining ridge heights as
some kind of datum it loses the
opportunity for the architect to
exercise some flair and add some visual
interest in the street
so i'm happy i think with a condition
that would say to two stories
if that's members thinking but i would i
would hate to think that we would lose
an opportunity for a good design with
good roof to wall proportions
constrained by the limit that they must
follow the existing roof but if members
feel that they want it to match
the joining ruth heights that is
something that members could achieve but
i just worry that the design would be
heavily compromised
i hope that helps jenna thank you
um for for me i think given the location
of this building and the prominence on
the hill as council hoy mentioned
virtually the
highest point in holmbridge um seen by
many passing through the district
i think the quality of the design is
perhaps more important than putting a
specific
size limit and certainly i would be
encouraging
some informative that made comment about
the quality of design
that was required in in in this
location but but members we are talking
about
the principle of the development here
with all matters reserved i think
members have also
indicated that they would expect
the proper provision of parking space
as well with with this now
um i'm not seeing any other members
indicating at the moment could we just
lose the share screen please
for clarity right ah there are hands up
right uh can i can i can i just remind
you members
we we want to progress so it
can you please be fairly definitive with
what you wish to say
counsellor mrs shaw thank you chairman
you see some
for mike's strengths um mike can you
clarify
how many parking spaces this could be
short if we let this uh development go
through because i'm very concerned
that we would lose valuable
amenity space for the uh families
on this i just would like to
clarification i think i i can answer
that one that
it's sort of been mentioned already it
was too short pace
places short but the appropriate amenity
space
can still be retained by adding those
two additional parking spaces
right okay because on this report he
actually says three things
councillor wilkinson then briefly
chairman thank you for letting me come
back
um i hear what mr strength is saying am
i right in thinking that we can't say
because i understand the principle of
good design as well
um and i do understand about not
matching the ridge heights um
are we able to say um that yes
the principle of developing this into
residences
is acceptable but
only two stories or only ten flats or
or what because if they think that they
can get any two and a half stories to
get 12 flats in then clearly he can't
put 12 flats into two stories we're
going to end up with a really poor
design
so i just want to understand what we can
and we can't say chairman because i
don't
i don't want to outright refuse it if we
don't have to but i would just like to
you know i'm very uncomfortable with
this at the moment that's all i think
yeah the principle of the application is
for 12.
so that's the application the the hot
the height isn't
is something where i believe we can uh
we can add some further information i'll
just
ask uh cancer fd you haven't spoken yet
thank you thank you chairman um would it
be possible
for us to put cancer proposal in of
up to 12 flats then it gives us an
opportunity
if they put less in
this isn't i'll let mr strength but
the application before us is the
application before us
yeah that's important important to know
um
cancer stanley
thank you chairman um firstly i'd like
to
make a proposal that uh the the
height of the building is in comparison
to
uh the the height of the buildings
adjacent to that property
and i'm sure that uh somebody who is uh
designing a roof will design a roof
the same as what as a roof is i don't
see any difference if
it was next door to a church then i
would turn around and say yeah you can
go as
high as a church but i'm sure that their
design people could design a roof
equally as well without dormers in the
in the top so um and also
for the parking and also for the parking
to be
away from the rear of the property and
and the amenity space
closer to the property please
so your your first amendment it is that
the the scale and bonk of the
uh sorry the the scale and height should
be in keeping with the surrounding area
correct can we just take these one at a
time
because i suspect uh that'll be the
easiest way to progress
mr stranks can you just comment on
whether that would be an acceptable
um additional condition please i don't
think so chairman the terms like um
comparable and that they're loose you
have to think that the
applicant although they may be listening
to this this discussion
has got to think what must i do to
comply with the consent
i think it's clearer if you say two
stories
okay um because you know it's quite easy
to design
and show that this is two stories high
if if we start saying uh up to
and comparable it's a very loose
permission
except in of course that you know the
terms of this outline application are
pretty open anyway but you you've got to
have
preciseness to any condition that you're
putting so i'd be far happier with two
stories
cancer stanley are you willing to amend
your
first additional condition to include
that term
two stories yes please chairman
do you have a seconder for that please
councillor wilson
so that's um a an additional
uh condition has been suggested uh
proposed and seconded
to include two stories now let's just go
on to the
second element of what you said counts
to stanley could you just stay
state that again yes thank you chairman
uh
to to uh put the amenity space
directly behind the building and the car
parking
to the very rear of the land
okay mrs franks would you like to
comment on that chairman
i don't know if claire can show the um
the layout please whilst i speak
but it's an interesting point chairman
because uh so
the profession is divided over this our
colleagues at
urban design at essex county council
quite often
favor the same for the same reason an
outlook over to an amenity space
when the car parking pushed to the back
of the site
uh where it might be deemed to be less
nuisance the problem you sometimes have
there
is that uh a shared communal space
outside if you like private windows so
what we have here is quite an
interesting solution
accepting that this is indicative where
they've got some
like buffer space that's shown behind
the building
and then you have car parking and then
you have amenity space close to the
golf course area at the back so if you
wanted more
more a quiet retreat etc you've got that
an advantage at the back so it's an
interesting concept if members are clear
that they're insistent that the amenity
space should be behind the building
and the car parking at the back you
could put a condition on that
but again i just advise caution that you
could be frustrating a good design
um you know that actually gets the car
parking in
is in this case which is only indicative
might cause less nuisance
and then there's quite quality good
space at the back but i'm in your hands
chairman
thank you who just lose the share screen
again so as i can see
right cancer stanley do you wish to
progress
with your your your proposal
yes please chairman okay can i just ask
if there is a second
for councillor stanley's that is
seconded as well
so that is a second um amen
um additional condition right councillor
williams
yeah thank you chairman um i must be one
of the minority here and
um i think this is quite a good design i
like the look of the
front elevation and i think perhaps if
we say
start putting conditions on it at this
stage we may may well be
limiting the amount of design that can
happen you know
i would support this in principle as it
is thank you thank you
and um cancer fd
thank you chairman i don't know if i got
an answer from
mike about up to 12 houses because
that'll keep it very open
and not limit the architect the up to 12
plays
mr strengths chairman the up to 12 is
is vague the idea of the outline
permission is that it gives confidence
so um to say up to 12
uh is is loose in my view if members are
insistent upon it we could we could
draft something but i'm not sure it
would satisfy um
all the tests um so i wouldn't advise it
i would let the applicant
come come back with a two-story story
scheme and if he can't fit
two stories in which i think his members
fear if he can't fit 12 in
two stories um he would have to make a
new application perhaps a full in its
own right having established
the permission in principle but uh the
the problem with saying up to 12 and
suppressed in two stories you may end up
pushing we saw those 45 degree lines
early we may end up having to have form
going deep into the site compromised in
car parking spaces compromising
um uh immunity space so
i i think two stories is better
um but rather than saying up too but if
if members feel strongly on this
uh that they would like a condition of
up to uh i think we could
if you like reluctantly live with it
thank you all right
um council well concern you're going to
be the last one because
bearing in mind the constraints on our
time
i appreciate that chairman i just wanted
to mention something i said before for
for cancer stanley to consider if he
wants to add it was around the car
parking
uh mr strength said that the there is
additional amenity space that could
provide the outstanding car parking
um i would like to see uh that that is
included as opposed to it's possibly
included as uh i just wonder if
uh chris wants to include that as one of
his amendments or not really
because i would certainly would favor
that i think um
when we get to a full proposal
it is within our our our gift
to refuse if it doesn't meet our car
parking standards
so i i personally believe we all have
already have enough protection within
that
all right i'm quite confident that the
the message of
this this discussion this evening will
be
noted by the the applicant so
um i'm i'm sure um
mr irvin will tell me if i'm doing
something wrong but um
do members wish to take
the two additional um
conditions separately or are we
so that's a nod so i only need one nod
so we need to do that separately there
right um so we'll get we're going to
start voting so the plan is
that we will vote on the
additional condition of two stories
first of all
then we'll vote on the additional
condition of swapping
the immunity in the parking space then
we'll vote
on the whole application with or without
these two additional features is that
the correct way to do it
not have had right okay okay
so um just before we start any voting
is there any member that feels that
they've not heard
all of the evidence uh and all the
points that they've
put through transmission we've obviously
spoken
about councillor hookway a little bit
earlier
right we shall start voting
make sure i do this in the right order
so
the first vote is going to be on
the addition of a condition relating to
two stories everyone's
recording both german i'm coming to that
next i'm
slow and methodical um
so first can you please use your raised
hand icon
to indicate if you wish to have a
recorded vote
there's just one so that threshold has
not been passed
so can i ask those members in favor
of including the condition about two
stories
to please indicate with their raised
hand
okay thank you please drop your hands
those members against that condition
being included please indicate
okay thank you if you could drop your
hands
my my electronic hand doesn't seem to be
operating the chairman said
would you like to just let us know which
one you were voting for councilman eric
just done me a place
i think he's all mute i'm voting against
okay um
are there any abstentions
is the counter intuitive voting to
abstain
right i have that as
9 3 in favor of that that being included
so that
that additional condition is to be
included
second one which is the
um additional condition to swap around
the amenity space and the parking space
those members who would like to have a
recorded vote
please indicate
thank you that threshold has not been
passed
those members in favor of including the
additional condition
regarding the swapping of meaning in car
parking please indicate
in favor
okay
thank you drop your hands
and those against that condition being
included please raise
oh you've been able to vote it's been
simply working now
okay thank you
that's six
okay drop your hands please
does anyone want to abstain on that
that's the butcher can you just indicate
what you're were you on an abstain one
there
no that's gone all right okay yes no
okay okay can i confirm
um that was a tar a tied vote
right so the chairman's casting vote
will go on that
this one which i haven't had to use for
some time and i'm going to
vote against this one to give the
flexibility in the design
and note the points about the
proximity of play space to the building
so that so that means that
um condition is not included
right members we now move to the
substantive
vote on this one which is
um starts on page
7.1 going through to
7.8 it's
the recommendation for approval i move
that from the chair could i have someone
to
second me please on this one thank you
councillor williams
and it's the conditions as mentioned
through
7.8 in addition to also with the
condition
regarding two stories so
if any member would like a recorded vote
could you please
indicate now
okay not noted those members in
favor please indicate with your raised
hand
uh
that's 12
and if we could drop our hands please
um actually there's 12 of us here so
that was unanimous then wasn't it
so that item is carried thank you very
much on that one members
next we go on to item eight
little stanbridge hall farm little
stanbridge hall lane
stanbridge um as mentioned there's a
small amount of
uh information on the addendum for this
one
sorry i haven't noted who's um
presenting this one
tells
chairman this application is for the
demolition of existing commercial units
and the erection of three purpose-built
commercial units with ancillary parking
and landscaping
as you can see from the location plan
the site is a section of little sandwich
or farm located within the area of
stanbridge
to further locate you because it
appreciates quite a wide spanning plan
here
we have rockford over in this corner
here as you come around the bend out of
rochefort
onto stanbridge road and then the access
way into
a little sandwich will farm is a long
little sandwich hall lane here
and access to the north up here the area
outlined in blue
represents other land within the
ownership of the farm and the site is
located within the greenbelt
so this is the block plan so this shows
a section of the site that is under
consideration in closer detail as you
can see outlined in red here
there are a number of existing farm and
commercial buildings on the site
on the wider site as well as the
existing farmhouse which is a great
touristy building located here
so moving on to this is a bit more
detail about the existing layout so we
have
four former poultry buildings located
here
an existing vehicle of access which runs
through the site
an existing other building which is
located here as well as some surrounding
land
and within the application site we will
issue
the photo
the poultry houses are no longer used
for agricultural purposes but are being
used for other commercial purposes
through permitted development so you can
see the
four existing poultry houses just about
on this photograph here
the existing vehicle access would remain
and the existing other building which is
incorporated within the site layout will
not change
and here we have the proposal so the
proposal was to remove the existing four
poultry houses and replace them with
three purpose-built units
the proposal also looks to provide a
formal car parking arrangement the site
with the landscaping as you can see
around this area here
this shows a 3d image which i think is
quite handy to visualize what the actual
proposal would look like
so we've got 28 units in total and they
would vary in size i'm going to mix a
small
medium and large size units so this is
block a at the back here and we've got
four quite large size units here
then we've got the medium ones in the
central block b and then even smaller
again
in block c here where and they have
double entrances on each side
all units would use similar materials
namely red brick and timber cutting to
the walls
profiled metal roofing sheets and roller
shutter doors block b
would have solar panels blocks a and b
will be just under 7 meters in height
and block c will be around 6.25 meters
it should be noted there was a previous
application refused by members in august
2020 for a different scheme at this site
this was refused for greenbelt reasoning
relating to the scale form and design of
buildings
along with the whole site area not being
considered to represent previously
developed land
this application seeks to address these
reasons for refusal by reducing the site
area and reducing the footprint and
scale of the buildings
the key material planning considerations
are the greenbelt
economic considerations impact on
heritage assets
transport impacts landscape impacts
trees and landscaping
flooding and surface water drainage
highway and parking implications
briem residential amenity secured by
design and ecology
so looking first at the green belt
whilst the proposed works are considered
inappropriate development due to the
scale being greater than the buildings
that currently exist
the volume and footprint has been
reduced significantly from the
previously refused application
as you can see from this volume
comparison plan so on here you can see
the line of the existing portfolio
buildings
and then in the pink sort of looking
line you can see what we had
and considered refused in august 2020
and then the blue is what we're
currently considering at the moment
the site area has also been reduced so
the majority of the site is now
considered to represent previously
developed land
the proposal is now considered to have a
more limited impact on the openness of
the greenbelt
it is necessary to consider whether any
very special circumstances exist
to outweigh the harm identified by
inappropriateness and this is where the
economic factors come into consideration
local and national policy seeks to
support appropriate economic growth
the reuse and redevelopment of rural
sites to provide high quality workspace
as an important part of employment land
provision within the district
the proposal would support the rural
economy by providing a high standard of
and range of size and new business
accommodation
commercial space at this site will
provide an opportunity to address the
shortfall in space
and would assist in preventing some
businesses being forced from out of the
district
as they grow or otherwise remaining on
suitable premises or at home
the harm by reason of inappropriateness
to the green belt particularly
considering the more limited impact this
resubmitted scheme is considered to
create
is considered outweighed in this case by
the economic factors and benefits this
development
will deliver looking at the impact on
heritage assets there are three greater
listed structures within the wider site
little sandwich hall the lodge and a
wall attached to little summary tour
it is not considered the development
proposal for any significant undue
impacts upon designated heritage assets
and essex county council's built
heritage and conservation team does not
object to the proposal
with regards to transport a transport
statement has been submitted in support
of the application
which assesses the access operational
traffic and transportation issues
associated with the proposed development
it is not considered that development
would give rise to any highway safety
issues
and this position is confirmed by the
formal consultation response received
from essex highways
looking at landscape impacts the
applicant has provided a landscape and
visual assessment with the application
this concludes an officer's agree that
no wider landscape harm would arise as a
consequence of the proposed development
looking at trees and landscaping no
existing trees will be affected by the
development
the council's agricultural and ecology
officer has no objection to the proposal
the addendum highlights an additional
comment from the council's agricultural
officer referring to existing trees on
the site
to clarify the agents confirmed that
these existing trees were moved last
year
and a comprehensive replacement planting
scheme with more tree planting
will be undertaken as part of this
scheme as shown in the landscaping plan
we'll just bring up that landscaping
plan now just to show you
so this is what they're planning here um
various or trees um a tree-lined aliens
along here
and then we have also immediacy areas
within the actual site itself
james church has since suggested that
some instant trees such as oak
hornbeam field maple or cherry would
give similar screening to those removed
and the landscaping addition will be
amended to require inclusion of some of
these species
looking at flooding and surface water
drainage the site is located in flood
zone one
the lead local flood authority has no
objection to the proposed development
subject to the imposition of two
standard conditions
higher end parking implications the
parking standards document sets out
maximum parking standards for uses such
as that proposed
the 31 spaces proposed here include a
disable base the appropriate size
dimensions is considered acceptable the
provision of a cycle shelter is
controlled by condition
looking at briam the development will be
required to meet the briem rating of
very good and that's controlled by
condition
with regards to residential amenity the
main farmhouse is shielded from the site
by trees hedging
buildings so impact is considered to be
limited dwellings within the wider farm
site and little sandwich hall lane are
not considered to have any greater
impact from the development than the
existing use
and moving on to secure by design essex
police initially raised concern
regarding the lack of details
surrounding security of the design
but the applicant met with essex police
and these concerns have now been
addressed
additional security measures can be
incorporated into the build
specification
and finally ecology the back declaration
form submitted confirms it is unlikely
that bats will be present within the
existing buildings
there is the potential for biodiversity
enhancement through native planting at
the site
and the landscaping plan which has been
conditioned for implementation shows
native
native hedging to be provided chairman
this application is recommended for
approval
subject to conditions including the
additional use restriction condition
which is referred to on the addendum
and a slight amendment to the
landscaping edition to require some
instant impact tree planting
thank you thank you and we have a
speaker on this one miss kate jennings
whose
planning agent so up to five minutes
as uh as you know when you're ready
thank you chairman um i i don't want to
take up too much your time can i just
say you're coming across quite quietly
could you
just speak up a little bit please is
that better for you
yeah yeah um i don't want to take up too
much of your time because claire's
provided a very comprehensive um summary
of the development
the committee did consider a proposal
similar
back in september august september last
year
that proposal was refused because of its
scale and extension into the green belt
the site has been significantly reduced
both in scale and height but also in the
spread of the development
which is now entirely within the area of
land considered to be previously
developed
land and therefore the development is
appropriate development in the green
belt
um in taking on board the officer's
comments in the previous application the
scale has been reduced down as you can
see from the plans before you
the footprint of the buildings is
reduced by some 28 from the previous
application that was refused the volume
has been reduced by 30
and the ridge height in most cases has
been reduced by over
1.3 metres all of these amendments have
considerably reduced the impact of this
proposal in the green blood and it's
felt that this revised design is
compatible with this rural setting
as claire had said national and local
planning policy supports economic growth
and the council's own economic land
study update highlights the shortfall of
grow on commercial space within the
district
and this is especially pronounced in the
rochelle area workspace is a
present in the district generally in low
supply and of poor quality
this proposal provides high quality
space in an attractive setting which
will draw businesses to the area
the design of the development is such
that there is provision for smaller
businesses to grow
on within the same site rather than
having to move and relocate
it's important to note that there have
been no objections we've worked hard
with the
um council teams to ensure that there
are no objections to this proposal
they take highways essex flood the built
heritage and conservation team and the
agricultural officer all in agreement
with this proposal
uh there have been no objections to many
members of the public on this proposal
um it's considered this proposal offers
exceptionally high quality design
commercial space to support the economy
in the russian area and i would urge
members to support this proposal
thank you thank you very much
so just a reminder members are in
addition to the report we've got one
uh additional condition from the
addendum plus a slight adjustment
uh with regard to instant planting uh
we've had a very thorough report on this
one
oh hands are just suddenly starting to
pop up i can just ask if
none of the non-members wishing to speak
okay uh cancer steptoe please
i've got a little bit of concern about
access to the site
uh i believe i'm correct in saying that
the access road
is owned by the uh the same landowner
and there is a footpath that runs along
there uh obviously our footpaths are in
great demand at the moment and of course
there is a lot of encouragement to keep
people
using the footpaths my concern is it's
quite a narrow road
and with the increase in traffic that is
likely to cause
um i'd like to see the landowner perhaps
put in some
safe havens so people that are walking
the footpath
can step aside quite safely for traffic
to
come past the fields do go right up to
the edge of the road of course if it's
cropped in there
the farmer won't be too happy about the
uh the public dumping into his fields
so perhaps that's something i would like
to propose as a
an additional condition um and i don't
think he'll take an awful lot of work on
behalf of the landowner
to put a few safety spaces along the
access road
thank you again to the wilkinson
thank you chairman um i fully support
this i think it's uh
um it's we should recognize the efforts
made by the applicant to reduce
um to all to acknowledge the concerns of
the committee last time around
and particularly at this time when
businesses are suffering that we've got
to reach
rejuvenation of the economy as well so i
fully support this and
so thank you thank you councillor
williams
thank you chairman um yeah i think this
is a much improved application
one last time we would have no issues in
supporting this
thank you thank you council stanley
thank you chairman um was there any any
information from essex highways i didn't
uh i think grasp anything from claire
uh from essex highways as to the the uh
entrance or the road leading to
the premises okay we'll come back to the
questions in there
counselor mrs thank you chairman um
i would concur with what uh councillor
steptoe has said regarding um
i can't remember sorry mike i can't
remember what you said for
um pathways
thank you uh for pedestrians
the the applicant has done a lot of work
down that road to try and make it safe
um already and i would fully support
this
um application thank you okay
thank you uh can i just ask you claire
to just best comment on
the uh suggestion that council steptoe
has made and how that might
be achieved or not are your thoughts on
that please i think
um if we have no concerns from county
highways
with regards to safety and obviously
they also have um
the essex public rights away section
within their department
um that look at that kind of thing as
well i think we would be in difficult
position to actually acquire that as
part of this application if they haven't
raised any actual highway safety issues
with it
um what i think perhaps we could do is
maybe add it as an informative and the
landowner themselves can
consider that if it's a if it's
something that they may wish to include
as a reasonable landowner then that
might be a better approach with this one
council um i'll just ask if you
how you wish to pursue on on that point
you made
would you be happy with an informative
thank you chairman um i believe the road
is actually a private road i don't
believe it's part of the highway network
other than the footpath itself
so i'm not certain that uh county
highways would have perhaps seen it in
that particular light
but if it's better than officers
revising that it should be an
informative
um i'd be happy to accept that okay
thank you
um members we've got a as we said a
comprehensive application
and we've had a comprehensive report
there is a
recommendation for approval printed on
8.1
through to 8.7 plus the addendum
and uh and small modification
plus the addition of an informative
with regard to um pedestrians
um i'll move that from the check would
someone care to second me on that one
[Music]
thank you very much we'll move to the
vote on that and i'll just confirm that
everyone has
heard all the information no one got cut
off and feels that they're
um unable to take a proper and accurate
uh
decision on this that's good okay
those members who would like to have a
recorded vote on this could you please
indicate
by raising your hand
no one's indicating that thank you so
those members
in favor of the application as outlined
with the adjustments please indicate
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
bye thank you if you'd like to just drop
your hands please
that is unanimously approved
thank you very much on that one
next we move on to item nine
which is um
38 to 40 west script
sorry west street rochford
and uh this is mr strengths again
thank you chairman um this application
is to a site on the northern side of
west street
just off the market square in the
rochefort town centre
i don't have claire's able the location
plan in the top right just
if you just alert members to where the
site is edge red that'd be great please
the site was now is a double unit
comprising two shops
uh that sold carpets and furnishings but
is now vacant
um whilst uh if we could see
the lower part of the screen if that's
possible clear where the indent is to
the front
front of number 40. yeah that's great
thank you whilst on this planet it's
worth noting that the
recess to the unit which is number 40
the slightly triangular shape yes thank
you where the cursor was
where it says 6.08 meters width
um it's worth members noting as we as we
carry on
uh that the shop front is recessed um
and although there has been some
intervening work uh the premises for
many years had metal
window frames and though old and with
the remodeled frontage the building is
not statutory listed so it's in the
conservation area it's an old building
but it's not statutory listed
um if we could jump to the proposed
elevations please two plans 40.
um planning permission is now sought for
a new shop front
but members will see from the image at
the top of the
drawing that the recess is being
retained because this allows for
the provision of an access ramp
it's a proposal that is related to
a proposed banking hub prior to
september chairman it would have
required a change of use but the
government changes to the use classes
order putting all the town centre uses
into one used classic now
it's no longer necessary to require
planning permission for the change of
use
what is necessary is planning permission
for the
shop front alterations where they're
taking out what's there
and they're putting in timber material
that is black painted as you see it
holds the same
proportions uh glazing to framing that
we had before
but it's a more traditional material
the rails to the ramp would also be in
timber
and black painted as i said the design
largely maintains the former proportions
the access ramp and handrail would be
considered by the county council special
advisor to be a visual intrusion
but officers district officers are
finding they disagree with our
colleagues on this occasion because
obviously the building to carry on being
invested in would need a new use
and furthermore the recess at the top of
the drawing that you see there
largely shields it from uh wider
wider views met some members will recall
that the
natwest bank which is round the corner
although a modern building
also has a access ramp and handrail that
was modified in 2004
but perhaps more importantly the martins
building which some members would be
familiar with
was refused permission for something
similar in 2007 because of a conflict
with pedestrians on the nearby alleyway
and that inspector although went on
to to look at the issue of conflict with
pedestrians made the point that the
rampant handrail in her view
would not harm the character and
appearance of the conservation era so
there is a couple of examples
including one precedent on appeal and
for that reason
district officers are disagreeing with
our colleagues at county
and subject to the development being
finished in the materials proposed the
recommendation
is approval
thank you if we
just pop off the screen share so as i
can see
everyone in the hands all right okay uh
oh lots of hands uh just uh
right so any non-members wishing to
speak on this one
yes so i'll start with
uh counselor steptoe please
thank you chairman um as well counsellor
on this particular application
and looking at the general economy of
the town square
in rochford i'm sure other members will
agree with me that uh to encourage
uh improvements in the economy within
the town square the single biggest thing
that we can actually achieve
is to have banking facilities within the
square
or adjacent and square in this case
those members that come from
over in raleigh will be very very aware
that one of the reasons that people go
to raleigh
is because the banks there are still
open so i don't
i can't support this application enough
i think it's the single biggest thing
that will make an improvement to the
town square
encouraging businesses back into the
square uh
opening up of shops etc etc so it has my
full support journal
i i understand your your your sentiments
uh
uh cancer steptoe but in in terms of
focus
this is a new shop front and handrail
application that we're
woody we're dealing with so um
just bear that in mind please members uh
council williams
yeah thank you chairman um i have to say
um i visited this site
and the it's a bit unfair to call this a
ramp really it's a very very slight
slope that leads up to the front door
i'm not over happy with seeing the rail
there and i don't really think there's a
need for a rail but
would fully support this uh this
application
okay um councillor
missed shaw please
thank you chairman um although mr
strength
said about the two other places in
rochford
that have got ramps both of these are in
the square
not down uh west street itself
and both of them come onto pavements
a lot wider than this payment the
payment on in this area is very narrow
um and i i think that the
the ramp or the and rail is going to be
intrusive
to the area there's nowhere else down
that
street that's got um an end rail
and as uh council williams said this is
not a ramp
this is a slight slope there's a um
building
a couple of doors away from it which has
got the same sort of slope
and that hasn't got an end rails i
cannot support this application
dance leaves future
um i uh i'm very very much
in support of the principle of this um
the one thing that we don't see if i can
just have clarification
um we've got a plan showing the
elevation showing
40. we haven't got anything showing 38.
i take it that that has
uh got a similar spec where it is being
a shot a new shot from being put in
there
that um is uh is part of the scheme of
because we're looking at uh
uh condition for or looking at the the
the
planning application for 38 to 40 but i
only see 40
on the actual application um
the other thing is i am a little bit
concerned about the the handrails um to
be honest
if they're to be in wood they do
the the sort of the application size
that's been put in for there
i would suggest that that's quite
flexible and being wood
at the bottom there um it's going to be
susceptible to rot
um i'm not sure how this actually goes
going to the conservation officer but i
think
as far as safety goes i'm not so sure
how safe that would actually be
in wood that's it thank you okay
counselor wilkinson please
thank you chairman um i do hope bearing
in mind who the applicant is that
this isn't going to be politicized this
evening um
i like cancer steptoe fully support this
um
uh and and like council williams i've
visited the the premises i would like to
remind members
that the plans that mr strength showed
shows the front door is recessed
um and everything is going to be
recessed from the pavement so i do note
what some members have said about the
size of the pavement but it is recessed
the other thing to bear in mind chairman
is that the concept of this business
is for the elderly and vulnerable
members of the rural parts of our
district to prevent them from having to
come to raleigh
which is slightly counter-intuitive as a
rayleigh councillor that will be
stopping people coming to our town but
it is for their benefits and as such we
have to recognize that vanuatu
vulnerable and
potentially infirmed people may need
a handrail i'm not at that stage of life
yet thankfully so i don't know
but i would i wouldn't anticipate that's
what its intention is
because this is aimed at the more
elderly and vulnerable members of the
community
so i i fully support this application
chairman thank you thank you councilman
shaw
thank you chad i completely um are odds
with mike wilkinson there it's not being
political at all
yeah we're talking about the ramp and
when mike strength spoke about um that
west it's
uh the pavement is at least three times
wider
than the one at west street you cannot
get two people even with the recess you
cannot get
someone with a mobility scooter
and a pedestrian walking down the
pavement at one time
it doesn't work i fully will support the
business but i don't support the ramp
thank you okay that's the stanley
thank you chairman sorry about that um
yes i'll fully support the
the business but um i would ask can we
put a
a proposal or a condition that only one
side of the
ramp would have a rail to it uh
preferably on the right as most people
are right-handed
as it would be easier for disabled
vehicular to to get onto the ramp as is
it sloped both sides and from the front
i think
um and also is it possible
not i don't know whether it is possible
or not because it is recessed on the
property
so is it possible not to use wood but to
use a metal
as wood can be uh it will rot
over a year unless you i don't know
whether they put them in metal stakes or
something but
it will rot and if somebody pushes
against it
as a mobility scooter or something it
could break
councillor fd thank you chairman i'm
happy to support this
application in the way it's presented
and
i'm happy to support any any ease of
access into buildings
thank you i i wholly agree
with with you um can i just ask
for any comments or officer comment on
the points that have been made here
chairman uh if i may the applicant
has had to jump through hoops that you
wouldn't believe
um with the conservation uh guys
i i am worried that whilst i understand
the sentiment about
um use of metal and i take the point
about wood rotting
i do fear that um i think metal may have
been proposed before but the
conservation officer was
rather insistent on painting wood i
can't help you with health and safety to
do with one rails but what i
i think you'll see from the signage
application that comes later the post
office are
also involved with this and they have a
specification
i'm sure about access compliance etc so
that the second rail is probably
necessary for reasons i i'm afraid i
don't know
but i would caution members against the
emission of the wood because
um the uh i think the metal railing that
may have been suggested beforehand
may well have been dis uh objected to by
the
uh conservation officer could you just
um
elaborate on council eve's point about
the other
half of the front frontage um yeah sorry
chairman
the it being a double unit the use will
permeate into the adjoining premises
number 38 but they're not proposing any
uh alterations that i see
to the the shop front there is a signage
application to follow where both units
are treated in signage
but this one at the moment is all about
the works to the shop front to number
40.
thank you members i firmly believe that
what we see is
is uh what we need to to vote our
vote on um you're either going to be for
it or you're not
the the the nature of the location means
that the detail of the discussions
about everything has been fully
considered
and the officers have come up with the
proposal so i i don't want to drag this
out it's a simple a simple application
i'm only going to allow two more members
to speak that have uh indicated
councillor eves please
thank you chair um i think uh it's just
worthwhile
considering an option um on the
ramp the reason being why you have to
have handrail both sides uh health and
safety would
um uh insist on it because you could
fall off the ramp
so is there any reason particularly why
the the
whole of that area approaching the
shotgun cannot be ramped right
up so as it does away with the need for
any yeah
and i'm not going to um
turn down my my consideration i think
this is
worth approving but it is something that
gives me a little bit of concern
um and so i'm wondering if that can be a
solution that might be
something to be considered casa williams
yes thank you chairman i wonder if i
could ask mister strengths um
what is the height of this this it's not
a everyone's calling it a ramp it's
hardly a ramp it's a slight
incline could you tell me how many
inches it is from
street level up to the the um the shop
floor if you like
thank you
chairman if i might clear can you help
me with the drawing please that shows
the side i don't have a figure four
members
um but i'm hoping that the drawing i
believe shows a section through the ramp
will give
an appreciation of of the ramp um
height obviously it has to go up to the
level threshold which is the
uh where the door actually is
but claire may be able to help us here
five inches five inches
yeah i don't know is that one two five
five inches
125 mil all right
i can only do it it's an accident
does the ram go for the whole width of
the the shop at the moment it does i
know
i just wonder if is there a need for no
chairman
no the the the ramp to the
uh proposal is just the area you see
shady grey below the door
door bottom there um so
it doesn't it doesn't ramp up the full
uh
recess um like the chemist does next
door
okay thank you all right thank you
can we just drop off the screen share
again please
all right members um we have a
gem and just for those people who were
uh sort of in old money as it were
the equivalent um four inches
okay that point i've been choosing
right um members the
application for approval is printed on
9192 there was a tiny bit of information
in the addendum but no additional change
to the
conditions um i'll move the
approval from the chair would someone
care to second me on that
thank you very much councillor wilkinson
noted or cancer fd
um does any member require um
every everyone's heard no one's been
disadvantaged during the
discussion with cut outs it's going to
just stop them from voting
no thank you does any member require a
recorded vote
please raise your hand if you do
no thank you those members in favor of
the application
please raise your electronic hand
thank you if you'd like to drop your
hands and
if you are against this application
please raise your hand
got that as 11 1
okay that application is approved
thank you excuse me chair
excuse me chair counselor sure i'm i
want to abstain thank you
becky pardon i should have done that
that's noted counseling is sure
thank you um
item number 10 is the same location
38 to 40 west street
and mr strengths is taking us through
this element of the
application thank you thank you chairman
same plan we can quickly jump to uh
the next plan please uh claire three
three b um before we get into that i
would first
um ask members to note a correction to
the description of the application
i mentioned in the previous item
successive changes to it to try and
appease the conservation officer
um the description you have before you
is that the signing there is new
externally illuminated
and non-illuminated it all the all the
illuminated signs there was a hanging
sign
which also has now been omitted and the
illumination has been
omitted to um overcome concerns from the
conservation officer
so what we have here is signage proposed
to
number 38 it's all part of the same
double unit but you'll you'll
see that this scheme has uh a white
background
timber painted phaser sign that is that
isn't illuminated
and you'll see it's in black lettering
with with green lettering
if we can jump to the next um image
please
this is the drawing you saw before which
you'll see is a contrast it's in a
satin black color and with the words
bank hub and here you'll see the
logo of the the post office um
the uh as i said that signage has been
modified and then the revised
description
um the lettering and the styling and
including the use of the window display
is quite acceptable to the conservation
officer the window displays will be hung
on wires as you see increasingly these
days
it's a timber traditionally painted sign
chairman and on the basis of the revised
description
omitting the illumination the
recommendation is therefore
of approval thank you
okay
right um this one looks reasonably
straightforward and
without any members indicating i believe
we can move
straight into the vote the
recommendation
is printed on 10.1 10.2
i'll move that from the chair would
someone like to second
that thank you councillor fd that's
noted
um does any member require a recorded
vote on this one
no okay can i ask members
if you are in favor of this application
please
raise your hand
i count that as 13 already
so that is unanimous thank you very much
if you'd like to
care to drop your hands on that one
gentlemen
could i have a comfort break for a
moment please
um please remember
the members in fayette happy with uh
adjourning the meeting yes chairman i
would
like to come for breakfast five minutes
then members
thank you
thank you chairman i'm back
all right so we are not quite all back
yet
uh council hawkway are you back
there yet yes chairman i
am here okay right okay
thank you we'll restart
um item number 11
15 hey don't row hey not avenue
rochford uh an application for a single
story side extension
not normally one that would come to us
but uh
claire buckley is going to present on
this one please
chairman this application is for a flat
roof to single story side extension
it is before members for consideration
as the applicant is a relative of the
assistant director for police
environment and the development
management team leader for the northern
area of the district
as you can see from the location plan
the site is located within the
residential area of rockford
in close proximity to the railroad line
sorry the dwelling is a semi-attached
shallow style bungalow which benefits
from front and rear dormers
and an existing single-story rear and
side extension the dwellings long hainer
are predominantly low-lying and
single-story in nature
as you can see here this is the existing
dwelling and this is an existing um
garage carport
into the property and just behind that
you can see um a bow window which forms
part of an existing extension of the
property
so this is the existing plan we the
existing arrangement is being shown here
so we have a kitchen extension
and with bow window extending from this
along the side elevation of the dwelling
um let's look at plan before so this is
the existing arrangement so
that's where the um garage carport is
and this is the existing extension with
bow
um window and then this is what we're
looking at in terms of proposal
so here we have a single-story side
extension we've removed the
garage carport and it's attached to the
existing wraparound extension here
it would be flat roofed with roof lights
um additions here
and we have a few windows high level um
to the side
and a window and also to the front
elevation here
there'll be a one meter separation
between the extension and the boundary
with the neighboring property
the key material planning considerations
are design residential amenity garden
amenity car parking and ecology
so with regards to design the proposed
scale bulk and design of the single
story side extension would be
proportionate to the existing dwelling
and would appear acceptable within the
street scene looking at residential
amenity
whilst the extension was projected on
the entire flank elevation of the
dwelling
the one meter distance provided would
ensure it would not appear overbearing
to number 11.
the windows to the side will be high
level and would not generate
unacceptable overlooking
it is not considered the proposal will
be detrimental to the residential
amenity of number 11 or any other
neighboring properties
looking at garden amenity the proposal
will replace an existing carport and
therefore would have
no impact on existing garden area
with regards to parking the site
comprises off-street parking that
accommodates at least two car public
spaces the required dimensions
irrespective of the removal of the
carport therefore the proposed
development would not change the parking
provision at the site
and then finally looking at ecology the
bat survey declaration form submitted
indicates there is not likely to be harm
to bats or their habitat
as a result of the proposed works
chairman this application is recommended
for approval subject to conditions
thank you
yeah members uh it's a formality that
this one comes to committee
because of the connections it's not
normally will be a delegated
matter it's recommended for approval on
point 11.1 three points there
um i see no one indicating so i'll move
this one
from the chair would someone care to
second me happy second chairman
thank you um
everyone heard the presentation no one
was this has been disadvantaged by
intermittent connections or anything
they're all
confident that you're in a position to
vote that's good
thank you does anyone require a recorded
vote on this please raise your hand
if you do
i see no indication therefore to the
substantive vote please raise your hand
if you are in favor of this application
i count 13. um
that is carried unanimously thank you
very much
please drop your hands
item 12 items referred
from the weekly list we have one item
uh this month hill view house seven
hillside road eastwood
and mr strengths is again presenting to
us on this one
thank you thank you chairman um the
application is to a site located at the
junction between hillside road and
rayleigh avenue
um of interest to this application are
the group of trees which are usefully
shown on the
site how it used to be with a with a
dwelling in the bottom right corner as
you see
and it's this group of trees to the left
of the image
that that concerns us to fill members in
some of these trees are subject to a
tree preservation order
um and if we can go to three plan please
when planning permission was granted to
demolish the existing dwelling and
build two new dwellings subdivided as
you'll see
there was a condition on the consent
granted on the 7th of may
to that concerned the
area that you see hatched in the blue uh
roughly 45 degree 60 degree lines there
thank you claire
um that can set that condition
which is set out properly in the report
before you and i won't repeat it
required that details be submitted for
the fencing that the domestic cartilage
fencing
for uh particularly plot one the idea
being chairman
was that the kind of pressure that you
get from garden use
where you have preserved trees tends to
result in a lot of say compaction
trampling
outbuildings what have you that over
time uh threatens those trees
and the fact that in dealing with this
application back in 2015
this group offered a value of amenity
that it was felt should be best fenced
outside
of the everyday uh uses and the
condition
also included the removal of permitted
development rights to put out buildings
under this canopy so what was sought
german was a
was a fence the line that probably came
off the side of the garage somewhere
that you see or possibly off the back of
the house where you see
that lone tree to the to the left of the
p
to plot one still an adequate size
garden area but safeguarding
um those trees now if we could look at
two plan
please chairman if you can see
uh when we get there the um thank you i
don't have claire with the cursor can
follow the green
the the sort of orangey line what has
actually happened
is that a fence has been provided where
clara is showing there and then
extends with the dotted line northwards
along that side
and you see that the garden cartilage
that the sort of activity area
embraces and encloses those trees now
that's in
breach of the condition what happened
was that the applicant submitted details
to put the defense there
as well as the other matters to do with
the condition
and it was what we call part discharged
we signed off on on the bits that were
acceptable
but advised the applicant that that
fence line was unacceptable
and as we speak the fence that's been
provided
in that position that claire was
highlighting there
is is in breach of that condition now if
we can see that pick
five thank you members members will see
that the
um the fence line there we can just see
to the right of the word
the street plate hillside road you can
see the fence line the concrete gravel
board that meets us at the end there
that fence runs down the side putting
some trees on on the outside and the
applicant i think you'll see in the
report has made a claim that residents
of other properties have sort of created
a car park on that side
um but the balance of the trees then
remain on the inside
of the garden now the nature of
um rayleigh avenue is that it has
quite open frontages you can see some of
this here in the image with the trees
and the shrubs and it was felt that
there's a
an area important to the street
character and hence why these trees were
preserved
that is rather leafy and open and
when you take into account also the
potential pressure
upon those trees over the life of the
building these were approved in 2015
fairly recent they possibly have maybe
60 to 100 years of life
in the dwellings as successive families
occupy
uh this this property there will be
pressure upon
those trees as i say pruning
particularly trampling
um it would be whether you have somebody
who is pro tree
and would look after them or whether you
have people with other things on their
mind and the trees become a nuisance
so um
we can see uh that it would be
preferable for the condition to be
retained
the proposal before you is to revoke
that condition to lift it out of the
consent
do away with it and what that would do
that allowed the fence line that you see
to
remain it would allow for outbuildings
to be provided
in that area where the trees are
and therefore chairman the
recommendation is that this application
be refused and conditioned nine be
retained on the consent for the
development
this is great okay thank you very much
and we have two speakers on this one
um it's mr dag first
who's patiently waited for the meeting
um as usual up to five minutes
when you're ready good evening chairman
good evening
members you you've heard about the
condition imposed in 2015
you've heard about the fence you you
know that uh this house
stands on the corner plot on the
northern side of hillside
road at eastwood junction with raley
avenue you've just had an excellent
photograph in front of you
that shows the fence in question and the
trees
that mr strengths have referred to this
was plot number one of planning
permission
uh fifteen zero zero zero forty six
four as referred to by mr strengths
to the northwest of this plot is the
private
i.e not highway part of raleigh avenue
you've you've seen that in the
photograph the fence in question is a
standard 1.8 meter high fence
vertical close boarded timber panels
with concrete posts
on the north western edge of the plot
and defining it in relation to the
private road
and immediately adjoining the fence and
outside the ownership of the applicant
there is the private way which has been
widened by others to allow the vehicle
parking and you've seen some of that
vehicle parking in the photograph there
was one car
uh in the photograph when i saw it now
last friday there were three cars parked
in that area
right angles to the fence in question
the westernmost part of the hill view
house plot and the adjoining private way
are dominated by a group of preserved
trees you've seen those trees you've
seen them in relation to the
fence they are very tall in relation to
the fence
some of the trees are outside the plot
somewhere
in inside it you've had that from mr
strengths
these trees are largely mature they're
noticeably hard in the two-story houses
adjacent
the trees are clearly important to the
character of the area and nobody is
disputing that
there's some shrub planting along the
western private way side of the fence
which softens the appearance
and the housing in the areas of pleasant
suburban forms set back from the roads
with frontage gardens and car parking
well what about the impact of this fence
the application is made to authorize its
retention
it's accepted that it doesn't accord
with the 200
with the 2015 condition nine
what's the planning significance of the
fence it's very much
subordinate in view as compared with the
group of preserved trees
this is particularly the case in
bucemrale avenue you've seen that view
given its typical suburban form it does
not in my opinion stand out from any
aspect this is a matter
of course of opinion i do not agree with
the officer
comments in the report that it
introduces a prominent barrier
that appears as an incongruous feature
along rayleigh avenue
and it appears out of place and detracts
from the visual quality of the space
you've seen the photograph and i imagine
some of you have actually seen the site
uh yourselves i i don't consider it does
devalue the site's contribution to the
street scene
far from being incongruous i.e out of
character
i describe this fence as being a
familiar feature in a suburban area
i'd also disagree with the suggestion
that there's been a material change of
use
the wooded margin was plainly part of
the planning unit
created by the permission in 2015 and it
remains so
now and it's very interesting to note
that
none of the five local residents that
raise objection comment critically on
the p
on the appearance of this fence so going
to condition nine
in my view this condition was
unreasonable when it was imposed and it
would be reasonable to dispense with it
now
it's common ground that this group of
preserved trees is important to the
character of the area
the trees are within the hill view house
plot sorry the trees which are within
the hill view house plot they're not all
within the plot
have been carefully maintained they've
been recently pruned with the approval
of mr chouch your
tree officer it's the tree preservation
order that safeguards the trees
there are criminal sanctions for
interference with trees that are
preserved
the effect of implementing condition
nine would be to detach the western part
of the plot from the house garden
and leave it without proper boundary
security the fences installed does no
harm to the trees
preserved trees are often found in
domestic gardens silvia house is set
well back
there are no permitted development
entitlements for outbuildings on this
frontage
there's no evidence to support concerns
expressed by local residents to
as to impact on wildlife there's no
badger set in particular
the biodiversity significance here is in
the trees
the concerns with regard to further
development expressed by some local
residents are completely unfounded
and on that basis i would request the
planning commission be granted
thank you very much jamie thank you very
much
um we now have mr wilkinson
uh who's an objector on this one uh five
minutes
uh up to five minutes and i'll let you
know when you've got about a minute to
go
so uh when when you're ready please
thank you chairman good evening members
of the committee
my name is john wilkinson and i'm here
tonight to oppose the recent plan
application
seventy 21.0078 we live at opposite
number seven hillside road on the
western boundary at 101 ray avenue
our family have been present at this
address for the past 40 years
i like to add that the land opposite 101
was previously been owned by
a couple called ken and betty letting
the field out to ponies with a wooden
night shelter
later years a developer built on these
fields leaving ken and betty a large
plot
to build their bungalow on and part of
this plot
was set aside for wildlife in 2014 the
planet application 1400 289
was refused as there was no
consideration by the developer to the
western part of the site
approximately 12 12 months later
a sec second application was approved
along with a comprehensive
agricultural impact assessment was
which was provided and the dwellings
were dropped from down from three to two
the notices of decision stipulated 14
conditions including condition nine
however i would also like to note um
condition five which states of
the retention of existing trees shrubs
and hedgerows
on the development side which have been
removed
during and since my concerns were raised
when construction works began erecting a
wooden fence panel
with concrete posts around mid-august
2015
this was on the western boundary line of
rayleigh avenue which i believe to be
contrary to condition nine
are you to delineate the enclosed rear
garden to plot one and not be used as a
residential garden
i urgently raised my concerns with
rochester district council
katie rogers robert davis adam aldridge
and
then sean strutton via email phone calls
i only ever received back
out of office these were dated 17th of
august to the 26th of august 2015.
i also took photos of the fence being
erected at this time
this suggested to me that mr panel had
no intention of fully complying with
condition nine
following this i was later diagnosed
with a brain tumor
over the next five years i've underwent
numerous operations including
radiotherapy
up until october 2020
which prevents me from contributing
further on this matter
i would like to add that we have a good
community
neighbourhood relationship with hillside
road
and rayleigh avenue residents sharing
past photos
um which i believe before the
past photos before the development at
number seven hillside road
showing the natural backdrop of the
trees uh which was most
which was the reason why most of the
neighbors moved to this location
before i close i we the residents
um
i i we the residents on hillside rover
made the avenue
all agreed to retain what was there
before the
development was built on to number seven
also road
an undomesticated wooded area and
semi-rural character
and we fully agree with the case
officers report by casey ellis
thank you panel members for letting me
have this opportunity
to view my my points thank you very much
um councillor ward
as a visiting member and as
award member would you like to lead off
on this one please
yes thank you very much chairman um
yeah i'm well aware of the condition of
this property prior
uh to the current owner taking ownership
of the land from the previous owner mr
ward who i
knew uh no no relative i might say
um yeah mr ward let most of his property
go into a bit of disrepair due to his
age unfortunately
the area in question was definitely not
a night of wonderland
or a beauty spot by anybody's definition
if they had seen it then um going past
it quite a few times and
calling in and seeing him i find it
amazing
that what has now been done to that area
uh is anything less than a vast
improvement both in design and visual
immunity
on what it was like i find the officer's
description
in the reasons for refusal uh completely
at odds with the original state of the
area
as being discussing i remember the
original garden area as being totally
unkempt
uncared for full of rubbish at times
and a natural area for dogs to dispense
their bodily waste
so you know i really don't understand
one of the reasons i feel
the original condition might have been
incorrect is the fact that the original
bungalow
and its garden have been established
pre-war
prior to 1947 and i ever financed such
restrictions on this land
may have been unlawful although
obviously that's going to be a legal
view going on
by virtue of the town and country
planning act in 1947 and the subsection
in 48
which effectively confirmed the
authorized
existing curtign garden as a result
the stated reason for refusal i.e
material change of use as a matter of
law has not occurred that's my opinion
i therefore invite the development
committee to grant planning permission
thank you jim any other non-members wish
to comment on this one
no okay counselor eves then
thank you chair um i think the thing is
that um
uh mr dag and uh councillor walt have
missed
is the fact that there was a planning
commission
planning condition put on the
application that was improved uh
approved years ago
um and it's i find it's a
personal affront to the development
committee
that the applicant here has just ignored
that totally and gone and done their own
thing
um now i i i find that disrespectful
for whatever you think about the
build-up to
this particular application they've gone
about it the wrong way
there have been a number of issues that
have come to the council
in recent times where people have just
put fences up just because they want to
now we put a condition on there for a
reason now if the
applicant thought that they had good
reason to actually have that application
taken away
then they should have done the proper
procedure and actually applied to the
council
to get it removed and if they had good
grounds for it
then i would venture to suggest that the
development committee would consider it
um officers would consider it and we
would vote
in a a way which would be respectful to
the council
and to previous decisions that have been
made
i will not support this application and
i would urge other counsellors
not to because it's just showing total
disrespect for uh
for anything that's actually gone on
before thank you thank you
councillor wilkinson
thank you chair counselor eaves has
absolutely stolen my thunder
i couldn't put it any better myself by
my concern
um with this i mean i hear what mr dag
has to say i've heard what council ward
has to say
and they're probably both right with the
visual immunity of the
of the premises um but the mere fact is
we're six years on
if this was an issue they should have
been dealt with in 2015
um i'd completely disagree with any
developer or applicants getting planning
con
consent from the council with conditions
and then blatantly ignoring those
conditions
uh and i'm afraid this is six years too
late for me so i agree with counselors i
will not be supporting it
thank you council hawkway
thank you chairman um yes i agree with
um
the previous speakers uh previous
councillors
um that obviously there was a valid
reason
for uh this condition being put in place
at the time of the application and and
um the reason for
all conditions like this is that it's
not about necessarily the particular
occupant at the time
and now you may have a
view of um looking after the land
but it's about uh going forward into the
future
and it's also about setting the
precedent as well uh
we should not allow um individuals
um to circumvent um
the conditions um in in planning
applications
um we shouldn't uh
give the precedent for people to do that
and there is the opportunity for
or individuals to come back
to to the council if they have a
differing view and to
to put that through the planning process
and allow
that to potentially come before this
committee
for for the uh members to to consider
um but to uh to
blatantly ignore um the uh the original
uh condition um and then to erect
something and then
say well you know it's there now and
i've looked after the land
and stuff like that unfortunately that
that that may be the case but it's not
pertinent to this particular
um decision that we have to uh make
today
we have to support um the officers we
have to support the reasoning behind
what has been put forward before us
today because otherwise
if uh if we don't then uh we're only
gonna
be undermining uh the planning process
and uh and other applications that come
forward
thank you chairman thank you councillor
stanley
thank you chairman uh could i ask uh mr
strengths uh
uh uh that the the car parking that's
been put there
uh it was that uh approved or
or not and at the same time um i do
think that uh taking
the role of i know best is not always
a good role to take yeah i do think that
the residents should have
contacted the council before any any
work was carried out
um this puts the development committee
at uh on the back hill if you like
because
what decisions they made in 2015
they made those for recommendation
they didn't do you can do this and you
could do that
so could you with that question in mind
with
with mike strength could you could you
give me some answer please
no other numbers are indicating at the
moment so mr strength would you like to
comment on the uh the members
uh various points please
uh the only point i have chairman i
think is about the car parking area
and whether it's authorized or not i'm
afraid i don't have the benefit that i
don't know if miss dunn
does and if she would be a better place
to answer that question
yes thank you chair um yeah so um
part of the car parking to the front of
the site
has been constructed within that hatched
area
so that is in breach of the planning
condition as well
there is an enforcement case that's
dealing with
these matters
that shouldn't distract members from
what's before us
tonight can i ask you can i ask you a
little question
uh that is not that is not the
involvement of this
particular application is it no
no right just about the fence
right members um you've heard the
information
um i think it's it's time to to take
uh your decision i just confirmed that
all members were able to hear
the various points that have been made
and fully informed to make their
decision
okay thank you can i
ask you to raise your hand if you
require a recorded vote
on this one
now so chairman uh sorry to interrupt
you but could you just clarify
what you're going to propose that is
exactly what i'm i'm
moving on to so members the um
the recommendation is
that the request to
remove the planning applique the the
planning condition number nine
is refused right
so we are voting to accept the refusal
of the removal
okay hopefully that's clear for
for everyone so no one said they require
a recorded
vote on this one uh can i
i just um i'm moving that from the chair
is there someone who's
seconding me on that one the number of
hands gone up there
okay thank you very much so
can i ask those members to re members to
raise their hand
if they are content with the refusal
that is keeping planning condition
number nine
in place
i count 11 there thank you
if you drop your hands
we counted count 12.
chairman can i just say i think there
were 12 there yeah yeah
we've i've confirmed that i've had that
confirmed this council stanley just your
hand go down
right those members
who are not in favor of the refusal
please indicate that's the one
that makes the 13.
okay so thank you members so
that um that refusal
is confirmed
so thank you for the efficiency of the
meeting members i believe
now at 9 32.
um that concludes our business
and i close the meeting thank you very
much meeting claire